Last time we looked at basic sentences
and Volcker, Latin and romance.
Simple sentences have one finite for
which means a verb with person number
endings.
These contrast with non finite forums
like this infinitive in romance grammar.
A clause is a chunk of language
revolving around one finite contests.
VKC Library,
Tata [inaudible] case.
These are all clauses that you've seen
became,
they say deacon quote,
they say that God does Bna.
You sing well,
he can quote contest Beignet Dean kick,
Qantas Bang [inaudible] Bay.
These could Sean to be for,
they say that you sing well,
the mood of the second Ferb contrariness.
This example will be subjunctive
instead of indicative.
If the first verb has a whiff
of the counter factual about it.
[inaudible] I want that you sing where
you may or may not sing verses suck of
contests.
I know that you sing where
you are definitely singing
Romania and uses the word
sunk to connect the two finite verbs
and the verb after sa is always
subjunctive.
CouldN'ta she sings Fidel.
I want video.
Second day,
literally I want that she sings.
Notice the structure of sentences like
I want that you sing in romance in
English.
This is normally I want you to
sing with an infinitive to sing.
Why the difference? The subjects
of the two verbs are different.
Echo volume.
I want to contests you sing,
so they're attached with
quotes or romance, quay or key,
but this verbs in the subjunctive
there that gives us the right sentence
when the subjects of the two verbs
are the same like Eggo volume and echo
Canton. The second one's
left as an infinitive. Hey,
go Vallejo cantata and not ego volume.
Oakwood Eiko Canto.
So boy, you can tag your
Schulty where you can diary.
That's the difference between what
to sing and want that somebody sing.
But this isn't true of Romanian where
two verbs with the same subject can still
join [inaudible].
I want [inaudible],
which literally means I want that I sing
modal verbs are normally found before
an infinitive with this finite plus
infinitive structure.
Most [inaudible],
they'd be oak and Tati
classical Latin had
passive endings for verbs.
Contact sings.
But it is some,
those passive endings didn't survive.
But that doesn't mean the
modern languages avoid passives.
They've created other ways
of expressing the same thing.
Here's the one we've seen.
If you recall as said,
a with a past participle
is to Cantata Tato.
Yeah,
as script too.
Ilulissat Lewis script too.
Extremely common in romance is the use
of reflexive say with third person verbs.
Contact. Well, you know what that
means by now, sick. Untapped.
Literally it sings itself for it is some
scary bit.
Say Scream.
It literally it writes
itself for it is written.
The verbs number singular or plural
matches the number of the subject.
[inaudible] Cribbet the book is written.
He loves Libra, SIS, grievant.
The books are written this passive
with say this heard across the romance
speaking world from Romania to Portugal.
A few languages have generic third
person pronouns that can approximate a
passive French on Shaunte.
Romance in Santa Cleaver.
French leans heavily on this
way of forming the passive.
We've run through a range of sentence
types to give you a feel for romance
syntax. We've now seen the basics
of how nouns, verbs, pronouns,
adjectives, adverbs, and
sentences work in vulgar,
Latin and the romance languages. Thank
you for taking the time to learn with me.